pas convié croyez vous qu'il y ait deux
papas plus jeunes il ne faut trop d'écho
notez bien sur vos droits
johan backlund attention il manque
[Musique]
il faut rentrer maintenant batailler il
et quand il ne fait pas chaud
bonsoir monsieur coup franc aux
platanettes sac à papier
quelle allure et asus cette unité boîte
de vitesses existants grand modèle
à mon sens réservé aux enfants
dommage ça vous intéresse en ton nom
c'était chez kobo menneveux ils ont de
grands pieds je crains tiens vous en jeu
de mots
ce nouveau ça alors pathétique c'est
pour aujourd'hui ou pour demain mais que
vous soyez gentil est rentré pas patrick
nos désirs sont des ordres à ses fils
york itunes a pris froid mon nom mais
l'être
toi qui l'a pas bien bon rhume éclats de
la pauvre tu es brûlant au lit anon
attentions font ça à tisanes gens
pensent ils à boire a malheureusement
nous n'avons plus les cachets
anti-grippe en
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bruit soir là
ça va ça vient du lit aux épaules comme
les peaux ouest et moi ta question
voulez vous sortir de là les bottes lors
des votes j'adore / je veux pas tu as
tout aussi magritte jamais déçu
attendri par la grippe il nous n'avons
plus parce que je veux bien aller à pas
ta ville mais jamais pour au moins deux
heures de défense
[Musique]
religion coup tu crois qu'on peut s'en
passer par ford et beaucoup mon enfant
toute seule
une fois les attraper toutes au lit
[Musique]
alors comment va pas penser pareil si
nous avions des frappes
je vais ouvrir alors ça vient voir tata
que marc cherry grippe porcine et
l'époque de vitesse aussi bien croyez
vous qu'il y ait deux pas plus cher il
ne faut trompez pas voter bien sûr photo
à
ouattara parce que claude attention il
manque un
[Musique]